[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants au froid
j'espère que vous avez été sages pas
trop ils ont été sages
j'en suis certain les jeter son lait
voir tout de suite mais les jeunes pop
bonbon
bonsoir les petits pas d'une histoire
quelle histoire une histoire de
commission mais je n'ai pas porté bon là
mais ce vrai voyons un peu
quelle histoire voulez vous que je vous
raconte
c'est le coeur méchant ce père qu'il est
au bord du ms oui je la connais bien
celle-là cornichons se trouve au bord de
la mer avec son papa et sa maman tatami
que les besoins
la maman de cornichons range ses belles
laine de toutes les couleurs
son papa 13 des paniers en osier et le
petit qu'un sont sur la plage c'est que
fait aussi un sens il a rempli son petit
seau d'eau quand tout à coup il entend
une petite voix qui lui même oui il voit
un agent au fond de son saut un tout
petit poisson de toutes les couleurs
mais corniche entier très gentil remet
la girelle dans la main elle emmène voir
sa maison
loïc est un méchant qui la condamne mais
vous la connaissez mieux que moi cette
histoire
il arrive à la maison de la girelle et
celle ci pour le remercier lui donne
déjà libéré cornichons et racontant il
dit au revoir aux petits poissons mais
les perles dans sa poche pour les donner
à sa maman c'est ben oui il s'est perdu
et ils marchent londons
londres et ne retrouve plus sa roadmap
tuniso papa ni sa maman ni son âme ni
data et ils marchent si longtemps qu'il
s'endort de fatigue
il n'entend pas la musique que son papa
joue pour lui avec sa guitare
voilà ce que c'est de partir de sel mais
oui il ne faut jamais faire comme
cornichons mes enfants c'est très
dangereux on ne sommes plus à lui nous
nous allons les enfants l'histoire est
finie nous allons bouger tout de suite
le must voilà ce qu'ils sont gentils
[Musique]
non nous sommes fauchés
non non ce pont nuit bonne nuit les
petits la jettent annuel à 2 me
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors les enfants
l'histoire vous a plu oui eh bien allez
vite vous coucher on n'y va pas trop en
route mon cher nounours
bonne nuit fêtes de beaurains
[Musique]
e
à
[Musique]